la première image de vous à la
télévision date de 1986 et l'époque de
la mobilisation contre la loi devaquet
on vous découvre sur le plateau de
michel polac
[Musique]
qu'elle était celui parmi vous parmi les
étudiants qui étaient avec jérôme
lorsqu'il a reçu sa grenade penchez-vous
oui alors comment ça s'est passé
j'aimerais dire à vous avant de
commencer tout débat qu'on aimerait
demandé une minute de silence pour tous
les blessés in or
c'est cette révolte de jeunesse qui vous
a donné le goût de l'engagement
j'étais déjà dans une famille très
politique on allait distribuer des
tracts coller des affiches gamin mais
c'est vrai que je pense que chaque
génération d'une certaine façon à son
à son rituel d'engagement politique et
c'est vrai que la mobilisation contre la
loi devaquet
les violences policières évidemment la
mort de malik oussékine ça forge sa
forge un caractère politique
[Musique]